[Musique]
abbas calme
en train de râler là comme un coq en
pâte selon mme merkel tient à l'hôtel à
l'eau pétillante santé à l'eau pays un
secteur de l'eau pétillante dont les
comptes sont bons aujourd'hui je vous
emmène vives attaques
on n'est pas là pour parler de take on
va parler tout autre chose mais on va le
faire ici donc le cadre est plutôt sympa
ça change de la gare il ya des grands
stands il ya au range derrière il ya
facebook et google il ya tout le monde
plus chaud que les copains voilà voilà
ça va les gars à lui donc on est plutôt
pas mal
j'ai une question à vous poser j'ai une
question à vous poser
moi je me suis entouré de nombreux
fronts camarades proposer sa meilleure
les meilleurs je vous ai posé la
question de 12 et 10 à un mollet qu'est
ce qu'on va faire pour la rentrée il ya
des nouveautés il ya des bons plans
qu'est ce qui vous intéresse et un but
atteint suivi de chez toi au regard des
bons et juste moi j'ai une question je
cite j'ai tenté un truc et je trouve ça
c'est intéressant
qu'est ce que vous pensez est-ce que
pourriez penser éventuellement de se
faire un live tous les jours on pourrait
se faire en live sur instagram j'ai fait
ça vraiment rigolo hier soir avec
l'équipement est il y avait pp il y
avait quand un il y avait jose romao
tels qu'ils ont été nombreux avec karine
et aussi de nos tech et on s'est fait un
petit délire soirée de lancement de
bonne foi c'était vachement couple
j'adorais partager ça avec vous le matin
j'ai fait aussi un petit live on était
sur un roof top pas loin des champs
elysées c'est un peu très sympa et sont
des petits moments comme ça 60 des
lancements 70 kg un nouveau colis je
vous montre vif et avant d'avoir la
vidéo de test
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'idée est
justement de pouvoir alors ces petits
moments privilégiés où on échange vous
mettre les petits commentaires on en
parle ensemble tout ça en direct voilà
je savoir si ça vous intéresse peut
potentiellement vous intéresser oui non
quoi comment sur un stade ça me paraît
être plutôt pas mal
youtube suis pas trop partant part ça
comme ça twitter je sais pas tout après
pensez quoi vous les gars non un stade à
bord non c'est bien pour votre avatar
vote par la jet de vote donnée nouveau
vote il qu est-ce que vous en penser ce
qu'on se fait ça à ce que ça vous botte
tout ça va donc cette petite question un
peu particulière et je pense que c'est
une bonne idée faire ça tous les jours
un rendez-vous à ne pas vous garantir
d'heure mais voilà ça se passe un paf y
en ait qui tombe et tous les jours
obligatoirement un live pour parler de
quelque chose et tous les produits que
j'aime tous les trucs où on va tous les
événements je pense qu'on peut vraiment
se marrer et puis en plus en échange
direct questions réponses ça peut être
aussi vachement chouette en profiter
pour poser des questions sur plein de
sujets quels qu'ils soient et comme
souvent c'est que c'est un peu compliqué
patron temps de répondre aux
commentaires
donc gérer sans direct voilà ce n'est
pas ce que vous en pensez en bas ça vous
bon si vous êtes d'accord
un voit la culture tous les geeks pas un
voile ah bon vous envoie ce mot bisous
bisous